der kinderarzt doktor martin karsten
guten morgen dr kasten
wir haben gerade im fall von der kleinen
pauline gehört wollen jetzt noch einmal
klarstellen kann man sich sicher sein ob
die kleine im mutterleib bereits corona
hatte oder die antikörper von ihrer
mutter direkt bekommen hat da kann man
sich nicht sicher sein
antikörper das sind sogenannte ibm
server sind plazenta geld das wissen wir
von allen infektionsrate und es ist ja
sozusagen der sogenannten nestschutz den
neu bewohner haben die kinder kriegen
zum beispiel eine maß an kriegen weil
sie eben einziger von der mutter haben
und wenn die mutter eine chronische
infektion in der schwangerschaft
durchgemacht hat hat das kind
selbstverständlich an die körper von der
mutter man kann jetzt nur gucken ob
dieser sogenannte light darunter geht
also wenig antikörper jetzt in den
nächsten zwei drei monaten verschwinden
sollten
dann kann man es ausschließen wenn die
antikörper bestehen bleiben länger
bestehen bleiben ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit größer aber ich
glaube auch das wird schwer zu
entscheiden sein
da ist ja generell noch wenig erfahrung
ist lange antikörper nach bewohner
infektionen überschlagen insgesamt muss
man aber etwas beruhigen
die wahrscheinlichkeit dass eine mutter
die sich während der schwangerschaft
eine corona vireninfektion das ist auf
das kind übertragen ist weiß man ja
heute ist extrem gering
auch unter der geburt wissen wir heute
oder durch mutter richtig zu und
infizieren ist extrem unwahrscheinlich
und wenn es normalerweise kinder nach
der geburt von der mutter bekommen
kommen sie eben meistens völlig harmlos
deshalb werden wir auch mutter und kind
nicht mehr getrennt ist und kein
kaiserschnitt gemacht kinder wenig extra
gewartet dass man sagt dass man die
korona wir nach der geburt von der
schwangerschaft abriss ist hält man
alles nicht mehr für nötig mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schau dich hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren